hello everyone this next game was
actually played yesterday in the sings
hilltop 2017 and it's definitely one of
the greatest games Viswanathan Anand
ever played in my opinion well he won
the game in 29 moves and it was against
Fabiano Caruana
magnus carlsen also won his game in the
fifth round of the single cup against
what we saw in 29 moves but this game on
earth played was simply so good that no
one was really well even watching what
the world champion was doing so let's
see the game is simply an amazing game
we have c4 by Anand and E 5 by Caruana
the English opening we have a knight to
c3 Knight to f6 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 g3 we have b5 seek after Sun d5
Knight captures and d5 and Bishop to g2
and in this position Khurana played
Bishop to c5 he probably played this
Bishop to c5 move because nipple Nia she
had this position against our onion in
the previous tournaments they played and
Oregon played nice to be six here and
nipple now she well his position was
better after after a couple of next
moves so it's probably the reason why
Corona tried Bishop to c5 here we have
castles by Anand and well let's just see
this point seems well like it could be
captured but it's really can't if it's
not captured on e5 then simply Knight
captures on c3 Bishop captures on c6
would check Abbey captures on c6 big
captures on c3 and now this Queen to d5
movies so very annoying as it attacks
both Knight and the Rope here on h1 so
why should have to play button item back
to f3 and after Bishop to h3 well the
engine would probably enjoy this
position with white but no human player
would play this position would white for
a price of a single point so after
Bishop to c5 on and simply canceled we
have castles by Caruana d3 Bishop to b6
and our Bishop CD to the this well the
sponsor can be captured still because if
it's
I guess right now would not nightcap
Terzani five then you get a nice
captures on c3 Knight captures on c6
well threatening blacks queen night
chapter twenty one night after sunny
eight and now Knight captures on f2 and
this would the well win material for
black as this night is still attacked
and this well and I just threatening
discoveries so this wouldn't be be good
for white so after Bishop to be t1 and
simply plays Bishop to d2 I mean after
Bishop to b6 and plays Bishop to b2 we
have Bishop to g4 normal development
will move by Cora wanna rip the c1 we
have Knight captures on c3 Bishop
captures on c3 and rook to e8 and uh
none place b4 here we have Queen to d6
and now nice to d2 and well karana isn't
really interested in winning this b4
pawn he plays the Queen to h6 instead
and go for this Bishop to h3 idea so Ana
plays Knight to c4 at second got dark
square Bishop which is very strong and
we have a Queen to h5 by Caruana
attacking this e to pawn and Erinn said
that he spent really a lot of time here
and well he did think that rook rook
after E 1 was the best move here but she
was afraid of some sacrifices and f2 by
this bishop so instead he played a rook
to c2 karana
goes the rook a to d8 and we have a nice
capture some b6 see Jefferson b6 and now
f3 and Aaron says that in this position
he was kind of embarrassed about playing
this f3 move as he really couldn't find
anything else to play as you know so he
tried this f3 move and he said that all
the events that happened after that
well it wasn't something he had planned
it was simply in the position and it had
to happen so he wishes the e6 by Caruana
and now Queen to d2 we have b5 f4 and
now Bishop back to g4 as acting that e
to bone again we have Bishop captures on
c6 b captures and c6 and now f captures
on e5 and the here
plays f6 and Khurana said that he was
the he was really hoping for Ireland to
play the Seth captures any facts so that
he could push f6 and that this was kind
of a defensive resource for him but he
miscalculated the the next series of
moves so I don't simply plays each
characters on f6 and he always wrote to
e2 we have f7 checked by Anand kept in
to f8 and now a very nice move by Vienna
and he plays Bishop captures on g7 which
check and this was wasn't really a
surprise for Caruana as he saw all of
this but he did miss one move down the
line he plays King captures on g7 and
well we have Quintus III check this also
wasn't a surprise to Caruana
but he plays a rock to e5 and the next
move is the one that he missed I don't
find well this couldn't be called
nothing less but a brilliant City played
Queen to d4 and this is this is an
amazing move this going to d4 is still
well stopping this rook from ever moving
and is also attacking the rook and e8
and the funny thing is that the Queen
cannot be captured
if route captures on d4 then simply f8
with Queen this is check and dr. King to
g6 then simply Queen to f6 and this is
checkmate so if the queen is captured is
forced checkmate in two moves
so after this Queen to d4 brilliantly by
Anand Khurana tries Queen to g5 but this
runs into rook the c5 now now attacking
this rook twice and everything else is
still here so well there really isn't
any move for black to play here he tries
rook captures on d4 we have f8 Queen
King to g6 and now 27 check into h6 and
well in this position actually Caruana
resigned because well what what follows
is king 286 and now simply wrote their 6
check and Khurana has the part with ace
Queen only move is to capture the rook
or simply play Queen to g6 and go in
front of the rook but
whatever-whatever Carano place is
actually a foursome 18:6 with best
defense so yeah this is I don't I don't
really feature a lot of Anand games as
well I don't really prefer his style but
this is the if he plays the more of more
of the games like this then I will
definitely feature a lot more of Honor
and games on my channel and yeah
definitely a brilliant and this
definitely will will be in every book
about Anand and this this is the game to
watch definitely in the single cup
probably I don't know if if anyone can
beat this game it will probably be the
game of the tournament so yeah that's it
a beautiful game by Anand and we'll see
we'll see how he plays the rest of the
tournament I do hope you enjoyed it and
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and that's it
thanks for watching guys and oh I forget
after every video I do I do I do want to
know if any of you are Game of Thrones
fans what did you think of episode 4 of
season 7 so yeah that's it thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you soon